Duncan sur une échelle de un à dix
tu penses que tu es un six je pense que tu es un
trois depuis que je sors avec ta mère je
ne te vois pas te mettre en avant
mais tu peux essayer d'augmenter ce score  dans
ma maison de plage, c'est quelque chose qui est ça
et toute cette gloire maladroite est mon fils
merci j'allais nommer mon plus jeune
Duncan mais je suis allé avec Peter enfin
réparer son œil paresseux maintenant c'est encore pire maman
de commencer l'arête de son nez c'est
quoi  Je sais que
tu es le pire parent, il y a un
message dans ce ministère de Gaza qui dit que
quelqu'un doit porter cette maman pourquoi dois-je
encore porter ça personne d'autre ne fait l'amour
ici hein quelque chose comme Spring
Break pour les adultes c'est Joan et Kip
je suis le  celui qui ne s'occupe pas de toi en
ce moment profite d'une thérapie super je
vais devoir te demander de partir même
trop de plaisir ça met tout le monde
mal à l'aise wow je plaisante juste ce
n'était même pas mes meilleurs
trucs  une seconde, demandez à un artiste de
regarder et d'apprendre et vous
tenez toujours  g à peu près prêt à tenir j'ai
besoin que vous recommandiez plus de tapis est-ce que
le travail prévu pour la semaine prochaine est terminé,
donc vous savez que je vais vérifier tout
ça, oh d'accord, je n'ai
rien fait, comment gagnez-vous plus d'argent  que
moi c'est celui que tu attends mon homme
j'ai besoin de quelque chose aussi donc mon travail nettoie un
peu de vomi est-ce que ta mère sait que
tu travailles ici qui est ce grand gars juste une
fille qu'est-ce que tu fais ici
en nous parlant bien peut-être tapageur si
vous ne m'avez pas appelé ici
s'il vous plaît laissez vos dames brenner que cette
conversation était entièrement à propos d'elle
étant donné ni longtemps pour être nulle part
c'est là que j'étais Duncan si nous voulions
faire ce travail alors il doit
y avoir de la confiance d'accord
Oh  petit ami m'a appelé sur trois qui dit
que pour quelqu'un qui est à propos de lui, cela
n'a rien à voir avec vous
comment savez-vous parce que je sais que vous devez suivre
votre propre chemin et que vous mon ami devez suivre
votre propre chemin c'est le seul endroit où je  Je suis
content que mon médecin m'ait dit de ne pas mettre d'eau sur
mon visage
Allez,
j'ai un enfer de ton enfant ici,
s'il te plaît, tiens, tiens,
tiens